rouler où devrions-nous aller en premier
veux-tu aller en Floride vers le delta ou vers
le mur est la lumière pour toi quand
est-ce que c'est bon maintenant ouais c'était ouais c'est
bon donc je pense que nous devrions y retourner
parce qu'il y a un endroit  là où c'est, ça
commence, c'est plus beau, un bleu de mouvement
dessus
s'accumule,
tu peux commencer à
couper
maintenant et
[Musique]
maintenant
arrête
là, je pense que c'est assez oui, non,
nous devons revenir en arrière
h
ils descendent bas autour
d'eux
nous
le dépassons et volons ici à euh 100 nœuds
désolé 100 km km
ok euh le cœur va bien avec
toi bon cœur oui c'est un bon
H oh n'est-ce pas trop rapide ici non je ne
pense pas donc
je pense  le plan se termine maintenant donc on
recadre pour se débarrasser de l'ombre ok oh c'est
fait on va changer de
direction deux R
oh quand on arrive au coin suivant
incline vers le haut pour ne pas avoir l'
ombre l'ombre sur le
[Musique]
côté
je pense que je vais faire ça sur un objectif plus long,
ils font une
re ouais et là là là tu as des
chaînes qui commencent maintenant très bientôt je
pense que bien ici tu as un très gros
virage à venir pour un peu plus de vie B sur
le
long
à
un gros  gros rocher d'oiseaux noirs ici dans ce
qu'ils
sont donc on laisse juste
[Applaudissements]
arriver ici et on va reprendre
encore plus loin arrêter l'enregistrement car oh il y
a un Shad
ici
oh merde ok Shad est dans le plan ok
arrête
de rouler oh  tu roules
ici non je lui ai demandé d'aller plus vite oui
bien
les premiers canaux
arrivent par la
gauche jusqu'au
LIF B en remontant le canal latéral puis en
descendant bas le canal asséché et
puis pour finir c'est ce que je quitte
après nous devons  d'en avoir deux ou
trois comme ça sur le côté mais
je pense que ce serait mieux qu'on soit un
peu plus haut en fait parce qu'ici on ne
les verra pas assez ok tu as raison ouais
ok alors
[Musique]
euh je je
pense  il y en avait un un peu plus
gros plus bas plus gros pour
voler on pourrait descendre arrêter d'enregistrer
sur le
mur
tu vois ça ne marche pas parce que tout simplement
la caméra n'est pas orientée vers tu sais
la rive gauche donc on a l'impression
que  nous partons et nous ne
voyons
personne, pourquoi arrête-t-on d'enregistrer, pourrions-nous
voler